this episode of the pain game podcast is
sponsored by
true classic as you can see the best
fitting t-shirt among them by getting a
t-shirt these days that is flattering
and fits you is really tough trust me i
know they're either too big on the
sleeves too small on the sleeves too big
round the waist too small around the
waist it just doesn't fit you like a
real man should be fitted and that's
where true classic can help true classic
make the best fit in tears that are
silky soft for you and me and all us men
who've been struggling with this this
real issue for a long time two million
men trust true classic to get them a
decent fit and an affordable price and
i've got you covered with 25 off when
you use my code true
at true classic trueclassic.com for a
limited time so you better use it now
i'm wearing true classic now i'm also
wearing true classic in this podcast
you'll see the variety it's great go and
check them out links in the description
below but for now enjoy the podcast
[Music]
at one time i was homeless instead of
going home every night there was no home
to go to
life at home was very difficult i grew
up being abused
i lost my belt i lost respect i
embarrassed my family my vision was
pretty much non-existent i was able to
just about scrape by the medicals
i come out i have supreme confidence i'm
scared to death
i'm afraid of everything
i didn't care about living i just wanted
to die i got up and i felt the weight of
the world was lifted off my shoulders i
knew i was going to make a comeback
fighting this was designed for me and
what makes us who we are
i'm so far ahead of the game
my dream my vision for myself is to be
the greatest martial artist to ever live
i have always been a fighter there's
nothing i do better in this life than
fighting
there ain't never been a map like that
to me
[Music]
it's me and the big lad himself it's
weird look at the gun baby the gun shot
what's up training again um oh yes we
got to make this regular because people
just [__] loved it last time i've
been i know a lot of people saying you
got to keep doing this big news anthony
joshua versus tyson fury may actually
[__] happen after all of this [__]
that we've been going through tyson fury
has offered aj a 60 40 split and anthony
joshua has accepted
yes
mate what the [__] are you thinking
about that this fight has been one that
we've wanted for years now we had it
pigeonholed and then it got separated
both guys went their separate ways we
lost our collective minds like why
didn't you make this fight and then of
course andy ruiz said yeah you should
have made the fight because then he
knocked out aj
everything went to [__] but now now it's
now it's finally back 60 40. i did see
today that they're having issues on the
dates and i don't know if that's a big
deal or if that's going to hold things
up i know tyson wants to be on december
3rd aj wants to go on december 17th
hopefully that's not a big thing that
somehow throws us off so let's let's
just dissect this piece by piece
together because yeah the first of all
fury was on the radio beforehand saying
oh i did i didn't give them 80 20 like
he would have done that to me i know
eddie was like no no like
we literally offered tyson fury 60 40
when we were champion and he didn't have
the belt and he rejected us because he
wanted 50 50.
yeah and we are now accepting the fight
that he wouldn't accept
so
it's so classic tyson fury to come up
with this tyson
it's ties into a t
it's weird how this guy is cultivated
the the personality where he can lie to
the public just on a daily basis change
his mind on an hourly basis and nobody
even gets annoyed like that that's just
tyson it's just tyson being tyson
um he that what i'm going to say about
tyson is he you know in the ring he
shows up does his thing but outside of
it it's a [__] hand grenade you have
no idea what the guy's thinking at any
given moment like i have no idea i found
it frustrating personally as he's
like when he first came out of his
mental slump and became this sort of
reformed guy i was like wow like the
sincerity
the humble attitude like
and
that's some
i'm sure that's still there but it's
been a long time since i've seen that
version of him it's the clown the jester
the unpredictable wild [__]
and we had tony bellew on the radio this
morning basically saying look why is
anthony joshua being called out by the
champion it's because he's the biggest
draw in boxing and therefore he deserves
50 50. he he he made the argument that
he's the conor mcgregor of boxing
and i i was thinking about it and i
thought you know what i disagree because
conor mcgregor made his name being
dynamic in the cage but also dynamic as
a personality what we
what we became fans of with aj all right
stay hungry stay humble all of that was
great but realistically we love
knockouts
and
it's been a long time since aj actually
has looked like a devastating fight and
now that to be fair is because of the
level he's out but
if if we look at it i'm just going to
quickly bring up his um his record bro
because it's sort of
it put it into perspective for me like
how lackluster aj has been
and this isn't me like saying oh he's
not good anyway because obviously i rate
him very highly but
i mean you've got the two losses to
yousick which didn't gain him any funds
and you're not worldwide i think most
people were saying you should have
pulled the trigger you should have gone
for it more in both fights
kubat pulev who took to dragged him into
the ninth round and really should not
have been in there with him uh yeah it
wasn't a great performance
right
the andy ruiz rematch which we all were
like okay you jabbed his head off and
got out of there but you didn't you
didn't pile the pressure on the way you
sick did to him
right and then the ruiz lost
i mean was that was a shocker and i
don't know if he's ever fully recovered
from it
but we're now down to povetkin in 2018
uh jose like joseph parker which was a
boring fight like the
the level that aj was on when he beat
klitschko when he was box office aj
is
2017 that was sorry so
i have to disagree with tony
respectfully in case i see him um
because uh
you know he's just he ain't that guy
anymore i think 60 40 is actually a a
very fair split at this point yeah and i
actually think now with fury's marketing
and america and the wrestling and he's
become a big eye global star whereas aj
when he went to america it was
embarrassing and when he went back to
saudi arabia it wasn't exactly
electrifying
so like yeah the uk love them but
you know you're in america you you know
better than me me how do you say it yeah
no it i saw some people on twitter being
like it should be 50 50 because aj is a
massive draw and i was like yeah he was
and even you know i i've heard that usyk
and aj2 did 700k but
tyson like you said has become a
worldwide global superstar in multiple
assets to his name right you said the
wrestling he's also in america we love
him we we almost adopt him as one of our
own he sings american pie after every
freaking fight you know
so
not very well but he's singing
but
no i think that 60 40 is fair i don't
see any other way that you do that
because you know you're coming off two
losses and i know that's not necessarily
how you you do a revenue split it's
obviously marketability but
aj has become that guy that we almost
expect to not show up in the best form
you know and that's not a slight to him
it's it's more so his opponents but
you're going in against the best in the
world and tyson is the best in the world
or at least one of when we're talking
about the heavyweights now with usyk but
you go into that fight and you're
automatically thinking okay this should
be tyson's fight to win what is the draw
for anthony here yes he can knock tyson
out but he hasn't done that in a while
you know he's not got the reputation
that he once had as that one punch
wild has very much took that from him
and even the wild and lost the fury his
stop has gone up way beyond ages 52 yeah
yeah because because because wilder was
willing to die in there and therefore
everyone was like [__] me that was a war
aj has never
given us that level of commitment that
third fight between wilder and and fury
because you didn't have the caveats of
oh fury's coming off a three-year bender
like he he shouldn't be taking this
fight he should be taking more warm-ups
this was a fully prepared cronk style
tyson fury yeah he was a bit bigger but
still he's adopted that and wilder who
everyone wrote off as being okay that
second fight messed him up mentally he's
not gonna be the same
[__] you
he came in and dropped tyson twice
son and and that's the thing it's like
that deontay wilder
got better in those little three you
know whatever it was two three fights
anthony joshua hasn't shown that ability
mentally to be able to to come back
after a performance that wasn't his
greatest
and just shock everyone put on that next
level of performance throw away all the
mental skeletons and get back in and say
[__] it man i'm just gonna go whatever
happens you know like it doesn't seem
like he's fully let go of some of those
losses absolutely i've
i've not really seen a fighter change so
much
the way we're looking in a bad way you
know like the way
he's come back and now clearly is a bit
gun shy
um
and when you're a power puncher and you
become gun shy you ain't a good look and
it's a shame because we can see his
boxing technique has improved and i look
at him against you sick and i think no
way could deonte wilder do that for 12
rounds with right but the problem is is
the only well that still have a better
chance than you would because he would
actually have the balls to pull the
trigger and leave it all in there inside
six rounds so
let's talk about the
the the reasoning behind fury going
after anthony joshua at this point in
his career when he's previously rejected
fights with anthony joshua which we have
sort of proof of now why now do you
think because
a lot of people think it's slightly
cynical
um
of them to pick aj after two defeats a
bit of a mental break down there do you
think that
remember i i see a little bit of floyd
in tyson personally where floyd didn't
want the patio fight and then cotto um
sleeps pacquiao and all of a sudden
floyd's like i tell you what we'll we'll
make that fight
um
so
do you think there's a hint of that or
do you think he's just like i just want
to fight well i think there's a there's
a little bit of both right because tyson
was retired for all of like an hour
right and he's done this before i
honestly think tyson doesn't know what
to do outside of boxing i don't think he
i mean i know he has other things but i
just don't know if he thinks he is tyson
fury without
that ring i don't know if he thinks he's
the gypsy king without that squared
circle i don't know if he knows himself
outside right and so and his dad said
the same you know as much as we we take
the piss out of john fury he's like this
guy can't like retirement's not going to
suit him he needs to be in a boxing ring
whether he's coaching whether he's doing
it he has to do it i think he's the
whole time
i think this is a jay-z move where he's
like yeah i'm retired and then you know
when jay-z comes back with his album
everyone's in like i think that was just
his way of making noises
no i think so and then you know when
you're talking about why he picked
joshua it seems like usyk's going to be
out for a bit said he's got an injury
something he's got to heal up he
wouldn't be ready by december tyson
wants to fight in december and there are
some names you know i even heard the wbc
is looking at making uh andy ruiz and
and deontay wilder should he win
a mandatory possible challenge again
dude
i would love it though yeah but i i
think it is i think it's a bit both of
what you're saying i think he saw that
you know aj is just maybe not the same
as he was in 2017 when he was on top of
the world and that tyson has you know
again evolved his style to really be two
or three different fighters at a time
you know we talked about floyd
mayweather adopting two or three
different styles during his career and
sometimes using them all at once yeah
the only way you see in my opinion
anthony joshua beating tyson is if he
does knock him dead and tyson is
hittable in certain instances but he's
slick defensively he can go to that the
ottawa lean fight showed it i mean many
fights before that show the klitschko
showed it but you know what he's got
this cronk style where he just walks you
down puts that jab in your [__] face
and says eat it you know so
i actually think um you know don't get
me wrong i wouldn't i wouldn't be
betting on aj to win this fight at all
but i think aj with his new
this all depends on the mentality of aj
but yeah regard regardless aegis skill
set
is more suited to a fight with fury than
it is with usyk yeah i think
i think because usyk never stands still
even if we look in that mega round he
had where when we looked at in slo-mo it
realized that five out of every six
punches aj threw he was missing
um
fury does stand still and that's how
wild i was able to drop them multiple
times in in the fight
and i think that there's a real
a chance that aj could drop fury at some
point in that fight don't get me wrong i
think he probably gets up and kicks the
[__] out of them
but but
when i hear people who i mean fury is so
loved in this country people just repeat
what fury says verbatim and what they
don't realize is like fear is a salesman
like
real boxing heads we know what he's
doing but some people just repeat it and
it's like oh i'll beat that little
middleweight up it's like well actually
usic is a [__] nightmare style
in my opinion for any fight out there no
one's relishing fighting music i think
this might be part the reason why i was
like yeah give me give me joshua as a
warm-up for this little bastard actually
i do think that if if uh aj gets his
tactics right shows his improved uh
footwork
and and can commit with that level of
hand speed and size we've seen he poses
a lot of the same problems wilder did in
just with better technique not quite as
hard hitting obviously but
aj's fast though yeah i would i would
think he's his hands are faster than him
as well by the way like his fitness in
the usuk fights really impressed me even
though he never
put like never went for it
the way he managed to stay with him for
like ten rounds i was like okay this is
really for a guy as big as yeah six
rounds [__] what i was doing in three
rounds man he was in three rounds he
just was going off of pure will now
those first six rounds in the second
fight you know let's give aj's flowers
here he he did what the game plan was
for him and stay in front of usyk right
to try to walk him into certain places
and get shots off the problem was he
just wasn't able to get those shots to
where he wanted to throw him
consistently but he was there right he
was in front of him and
this is the thing too like we're talking
about the matchup now with with
uh aj and tyson you can't go and try to
bully aj like you can't cronk style in
my opinion i don't think you can just
walk i know tyson's 290 but you can't
just walk aj down and bully him in my
opinion yeah you could do that a while
though because his inside fighting was
so poor but as you've seen with uh
klitschko and this was years ago don't
get me wrong but fury showed him a lot
of respect and it wouldn't surprise me
if we see the slick fury until the late
around yeah no i was gonna say like the
clinch game from from aj isn't deante's
he still has one of the best uppercuts
left hooks in the game you know so you
get close with him and you want to start
exchanging in the pocket you know it
seems like fury can take a bunch of body
shots with that gut
but he's coming upstairs with that
uppercut and he's hitting the hook
behind it and all of a sudden you're on
wobblesville you know so
i think that yeah i think he is going to
have to adopt a more slick style not
just necessarily the ottowa lean fight
where he's just kind of laying on the
ropes and you know shifting way back and
forth but i think he's going to have to
again
patient aggressive pressure with a
counter fighter mentality almost you
know i always talked about conor
mcgregor being a counter an offensive
counter fighter i just see the same
thing here with
them making the mistakes and then
punishing them just on the edge of range
sort of thing yeah i think i think tyson
does something like that but again like
you said a style that aj has here is
conducive because he is technically
tight you know he's not wild he's not
deontay wilder and he's not wild right
so if he throws things with a technical
basis behind it and doesn't over extend
on shots and is around in the later
rounds to carry that power tyson is
available sometimes and he can get hit
my only thing with aj coming in this
fight in terms of
obviously the technical
difference between the two is he has to
become more unpredictable i felt i feel
like that's why you say cruised past him
both times is music just seeing the
punches coming and
he was on the edge of him or bouncing
off the gloves and i feel furi's vision
is going to be similar you know so he
has to i think he may end up getting a
new coach because he's been lied to by
his last two [__] coaches broad day
like me both of them saying you're
winning every round just [__] lying
to him he needs a coach who's going to
be straight with him and try and make
him less predictable
if i was if i was anthony joshua i would
i would come and train in america i
would i would come and get and get away
from everything that's going on over
there maybe not with robert garcia i
don't know if he wants to stay there and
go with robert cool but yeah somewhere
just get away from from everything that
you know is is comfortable
that you've done before and come out
here and get some good work with a real
gym not to say he's not in one but with
a real gym here in the u.s
yeah i'm sick of when you hear oh he's
in sheffield and all of that i'm just
like man it's
it's just not leveling him up enough man
you know he's for the athletic specimen
ages he has
not fulfilled his potential
in my opinion and i think he needs a
[__] sports psychologist desperately
as well by the way yeah no jesus that
might be the most important thing
yeah no if he doesn't already have one
that i'm shocked that he doesn't but it
just seems like a spider web you know
he's just trying to untangle everything
and you kind of saw it in that post
fight everything come out at once and
yeah he definitely needs someone to be
able to to
just write all those thoughts you know
just to be able to direct them because
he has good intentions and i think he
in those little moments like even when
he was talking about he talked to he was
like he was like why did you beat me he
was asking who's going to beat him and
he was like
he's like he's like it wasn't because i
because usually trying to say you're a
good boxer man
you're very strong and he's like yeah
he's like yeah doesn't mean anything he
doesn't mean anything why don't you be
but like he he has good intentions his
mind is in the right place he wants to
become the best boxer not just the most
powerful guy but
his way of going about it and when it
doesn't necessarily work out for him
it's hard for him to handle i've got to
give credit aj really because
you know after everyone thought he was
the money man and all of this and and
you can only imagine how sick eddie
hearn is to have to take
40 percent of this of this fight when he
has held all the marbles for the longest
[__] time with aj has always been the
a side the fact that he's going in there
he's like my god and if fury trashes aj
in style
you ain't going out there
and and that does own deal all of a
sudden whoa
that is
bad value
you know and um but i got to give credit
aj just went yeah [__] it take it you
know immediately and
and showed
he really is about that life and
most fighters and i've seen a lot of
boxing experts coming out pro boxers
saying he needs some confidence building
fights he needs a trash can he needs a
dillian white and then he needs a big
fight so he's literally going
out of the frying pan and into the fire
from music the fury and that at this at
this point in history that's the two
hardest fights in the heavyweight
division yeah yeah no you can't you
can't like say what you want about you
know aj's mindset maybe being off with
some of these fights or him not pulling
the trigger in the ring but him taking
these fights even the music rematch
right away like you're seeing a guy that
maybe isn't necessarily where he needs
to be technically your skill or mindset
wise yet but he still has that right
still believes that he can go out and
compete with the best so i want to take
that
my one hope is that what we didn't get
from aj in the yusik fight was the anger
the ridge yeah bring it out and tyson
fury will bring that out of you i i
really hope he does because we need to
see aj like angry as [__] and wanting to
take this guy's head off in order for
him to even have a chance if you come in
there tame
it's not even worth it
no tyson is going to pop his jab in your
face while sugar here is screaming jab
the [__] in the corner and it's
not going to go well
all over him but this fight's huge man i
mean i know we it's that's an obvious
statement but wherever they do it
hopefully obviously it's in the uk it is
huge
and this is going to be one of those
fights that should aj actually get it
done
it rectifies everything like all of the
missteps all of the losses gone like
that because you beat basically what
most people consider this generation's
greatest heavyweight
me if if if if aj just [__] flash
knock fury out eddie hearn will take off
and probably exit the stadium via like a
[__] blimp or something like it's
gonna be wild and the one thing one
thing that we haven't talked about is um
in fury trying to rush this fight
through
i do think that there's a i don't know
if you know what floyd always did but i
pro yeah yeah floyd floyd never had
camps for more than five weeks yeah well
not that everyone else knew about so
floyd is in camp four weeks
he rings every and then he rings you up
conor mcgregor yeah you got six weeks
[__] be ready
boom and meanwhile he is in full swing
full kind of scrambling around trying to
get it off he does
yeah and this is i think partly is like
saying the state
aj was in he's like yeah quicker quicker
i get him in the ring the better and um
obviously aj i think it's only fair to
give aj till december considering
uh how long
was yeah tyson was saying november 29th
or december 3rd and then aj was like
december 15th and then tyson's like take
it or leave it those are the dates yeah
so i think you're pretty spot on with
that assessment it's he's a quick smart
guy and uh i don't think people sort of
realize and he disguises it well by
being this big baldy clown
uh who says this says that says the
other this is all him
putting out confusion so that no one
realizes what a [__] master he is at
this game and how he has studied
everyone from i've seen him in press
conferences back in the day where prince
naseem hamed was in and he was like me
i'm the heavyweight version of you i
studied you like this is real smart from
him um and
it's weird but nowadays the underdog i
kind of i feel for him a bit like i said
he goes out and gets this done man
like he's on top of the world or even
puts out a like you know like auto
wallet like deontay wilder performance
yeah you mentioned earlier aj's head
is like a spider's web well you know
what i'm going with this one yeah yeah
because anderson the spider silva is
fighting jake [__] paul
this [__] is oh my god wild
i can't believe it i caught a man this
is like mending me i know people it's
not even receiving the amount of like
shock and awe value that it that it's
worth you're talking about the greatest
fighter possibly ever and jake paul
it's not like
what like i have no other i don't even
i don't know how else to describe it
this is [__] nuts what what what is
mad right is how
people's hate for jake paul will always
cloud their judgment and it's it's been
happening i mean 14 grand
[__] out of ben askren for christ's sake
it's been i know but i was on the front
lines on twitter yesterday it is
crazy
i mean
the best bit the my favorite bit of this
whole [__] is where jake sits in goes
don't let me promote it for you
let dana why you do it and you've got
dana white saying how great anderson
silver is now jake paul would never
fight him
and um yeah it is a bit i mean look i
get anderson silva 47 years old
and he is not what he once was and if
and if anderson still there was that guy
now this wouldn't even be worth having
because no offense to jake the guy was a
ninja right he was a he was the modern
day of bruce lee you're right you touch
him you could not touch him there's a
debate on whether or not he's the
greatest ever in mma people talk about
khabib john jones george simpson what
there isn't a debate on is who was the
most spectacular
fighter we've ever witnessed the one who
made all of our jaws drop the most
electrifying man in mma
ever for me like it was anderson silva
i'll never forget watching him humiliate
forrest griffin in the way he did and um
the skills aren't quite what they were
but
he is still smashing people up in boxing
still got that power and the power's the
last thing to go
do you think people are still not giving
jake enough credit or is it just me
here's the thing i don't even think the
skills are not what they were his speed
is not what it was
maybe yeah maybe his chin is you know
everybody's like oh he's 50 and that's a
that's a fun little narrative to run
with his chin might not be what it
always was but anderson's still anderson
he still possesses all those things
people are not giving jake the credit
that he deserves at all for this because
not only is is and i said this in my
video
if you wanted jake to fight tommy fury
or any of these lower level boxers at
the moment
anderson beats most of those guys
so what are we talking about are we just
are we just saying fight a boxer for the
sake of saying fight a boxer like yeah
we
we're talking about a guy who in his
prime was gonna fight roy jones jr at
one point like he he ain't a bum yeah
this is not not only is he not a bum but
anderson brings things that jake has
never seen jake has never had a reach
disadvantage anderson's going to bring
him that jake's never been at a skill
disadvantage honestly anderson's going
to bring him that and so there's things
if you can't get on the inside and hurt
this guy
he will humiliate you and take
pleasure
in showing
the youtube kid who the [__] daddy is
you know what i mean so
it's gonna know
in so many [__] ways this anderson is
known for playing around and this is
where i i get a little worried right if
we're gonna talk about like the fight
itself yes this is massive for jake this
is a huge w win or lose because this is
one of those things too and we'll talk
about this really quick this is an idols
versus rival or become your rivals yeah
type game
as kids yes that's so cool to me jake is
normally the guy that'll that'll piss
you off to no end and he will make you
have this vitriolic reaction to say i
want to i want to fight that guy i want
to shut him up but for this one i don't
need that because i already know how
much jake adores this guy
and it is just the fact that he's
fighting anderson silva that sells it
for me and that is his biggest hero like
this is awesome but
this and we'll talk about the fight this
is where what scares me because jake in
this fight
is a massive disadvantage but he's
dangerous
and it's because anderson loves to play
and i don't like that anderson i don't
know he has to take jake seriously if he
doesn't and he starts coming in hands
down starts bobbing throwing out and
jake lands her right hand
the entire mma world dies like it does
it it's over if that happens
if if if those [__] hated jake
paul before
oh my god he's gonna need extra security
if he knocks out the goat i'm saying but
and that's what i think though like jake
has like he has to knock anderson just
to be clear
just to be clear for those who are
calling anderson washed up finished done
all of that yeah three years ago
anderson went the distance with the
middleweight champion of the world in
the ufc izzy adasanya this was only
three years ago israel adasanya could
not finish anderson silva three years
ago and let's be real it was a striking
battle there was no [__] grappling
going on at all and yeah there's a lot
of kicks in there but the point i'm
making still stands like the guy went
the distance with the champ of the ufc
now so
we're talking about him beating julio
cesar chavez jr exactly a boxing match
after that and again you know we can we
can throw the caveats all day and say
you know chavez jr wasn't what he was
when he was younger his work ethic
wasn't the same yadda yadda we're still
talking about a guy that was a wbc champ
like what like in anderson's second ever
boxing match
ever
and when you look at the last fight as
the anderson fought in mma even bisping
cormier brunson arisania canyoneer and
uriah hall all killers absolute
murderers role he's never had an easy
fight in his footballing life outside
the tito ortiz
uh newsville in about two seconds it
looked like tito was i don't know what
was going on i mean it's tito he's never
been a great striker but it looked like
he was on like slow motion like loop
mode with those hooks he was just
yeah
one of the reasons the ufc is today and
yet he's still having to get in the ring
boxing
anderson silva but i think one of the
main things that gets me is when the
tyron woodley fight happened i was like
i was saying people like three years ago
jake paul did not know what boxing was
he's now in the ring with the guy what
is it now four years you know what i
mean and he's in there with anderson
silva like yet and older anderson silva
whatever we want to say but like it's
amazing how people just adjust to the
now and go yeah but you know like and
i'm like you it's always such a hater
you are you you are such a [__] hater
it's unbelievable it's always going to
happen with jake fights it doesn't
matter when it was like we could even
that we have the the test cases when it
was tommy it was oh well tommy's a
little smaller or tommy's not a real
boxer or he's just a celebrity guy or
and the people that were giving him
credit fair play but then it was hassem
rachman jr oh this was your sparring
partner
he's not going to try to knock you out
it's already fixed why are you fighting
a heavyweight he can never make the
weight you're weight bullying him
there's always going to be something for
jake right it doesn't matter who the
opponent's gonna be i've accepted at
this point people just don't care they
want to to [__] on what he does and
listen i'm not the biggest jake paul fan
in the world but this deserves all the
credit okay the age is the only thing
you're gonna bring me and he's not a
boxer this is the greatest striker
that's ever lived he won 16 in a row in
the ufc no one can do that i don't know
what else you need this is this is the
fight and it's gonna be the only fight
that shows jake's inefficiencies from
the jump that he could have taken right
now because tommy fury jake that would
have been a pretty even fight in my
opinion
anderson is going to show what jake
lacks from the jump if the if there is
those yeah anderson just to be clear
after i mean look we don't know the
strides that jake's been making in
training
but based on his last fight with woodley
his judgment of distance his his his
knowing when to go when not to go so
many little i could list a whole list of
things that he that i just thought he
needed to work on so for him to go from
that to anderson silva now i'm it could
be a big [__] mistake big time and
and for people who are like oh and it's
old anderson silva i'm like you want to
get in the [__] ring with anderson
silva do you know that guy that we all
remember smoking fools
smashing rich franklin's nose into a
point where his face looked like a
pavement afterwards like that's
ingrained in our mind so when jake gets
in there he's seen all the knockouts
i've seen that you've seen you got the
guy looking at you with his [__] eyes
wide open on you and you're like
there's got to be a moment in jake's
head where he goes holy [__] it's
anderson silva and i've got to fight
like
it's very hard to remove that mental
component of i'm in there with a living
legend right now and um
that just takes guts and it takes bowls
i think jake is just [__] crazy i
honestly do like i don't think there's
anything that goes on in this guy's head
that
he has any fear of any any individual
you know like i maybe you know if it was
someone like okay you like pick a
massive heavy somebody like that but
he's talking about fighting canelo like
i know that as a normal person as a
realist i wouldn't say those things
because i'm i know that's [__] crazy
but i think jake is just [__] nuts
and i think this is another testament to
that he doesn't look yes he looks at
anderson as one of his heroes but he
looks at a way to get to that next level
and if that means like he said
exterminating the spider okay like here
we go
you have to almost borderline on being
delusional
to reach the pinnacle of your potential
in anything always yeah always said this
about jake he is delusional to the
highest degree that makes him that like
you said those three years that he took
and all of a sudden he's knocking out
tyron woodley he got there because he
was delusionally confident in his skill
and his ability obviously we'll break
the fight down the close out of the time
but right now we both accept this
biggest challenge by a mile and you've
interviewed ksi a lot and ksi is
building to
a fight against jake paul what the [__]
does that do
this
fight it all of a sudden just when we
feel it all right ksi's back he's
catching jake up jake then goes and does
something like this in him i mean like
what do you think jj is thinking looking
at this fight being announced after he's
just had all of that flack for something
where i mean jj didn't get flak
personally but the event
got criticized for the level of
opponents he was fighting where he's
fighting guys who look like they've well
they literally haven't put a pair of
gloves on before by the looks of it and
then jake paul's getting in there with
anderson [__] silva what's going
through jj's mind in your opinion it's
tough for for jj because he he i know is
actively trying like you said to get to
jake
and you know i had a discussion with my
boy sensei on our podcast about this
like we were talking about the draws
like who's the biggest draw and he made
such a good point to me he was like the
biggest draw that ksi is going to have
is jake you know and jake is now looking
to go to conor mcgregor and anderson
silva and he's just boom boom boom
that's because of what jake's achieved
rather than his actual likes
like celebrity power you know like yeah
jake has sort of gone beyond and has now
take being taken more seriously as an
actual fighter as a boxer right yeah so
for for jj you got to look at this and
say you know i i think he's looking at
it and saying what we're saying like
damn respect you know okay he's going
out and doing that if you're jj
there's a time frame here that you have
to do this in my opinion you know yeah
all of a sudden the windows got a little
tighter yeah the longer it goes and the
longer it we'll see though like jake
still has to win fights so he goes out
there and gets smoked by anderson and
the whole thing opens up again you know
but the longer this goes and longer jake
continues to up the levels and win it
that fight becomes you know further and
further apart because then jj has to
almost replicate what jake's doing in a
different way you know but like he has
to get i think
uh sorry to interrupt you i think he can
um
it's a bit like the joshua fury scenario
in that people will always want to say
it
yeah but
we're now going into that fight just
thinking well
fury probably you know what i mean like
and we might be in a similar scenario
where
if let's say jj fights slim and jake
paul fights anderson and these are all
big ifs in terms of what happens in
those fights but let's just say for
example
if jake paul sleeps anderson silva
and and jj goes to a decision and wins
the decision against slim people
immediately are just going to be like
well
this in
on a we're not on a level here where we
can actually buy into this as a
competitive fight that's that's the
issue
yeah no i think that regardless of of
what you look for in the if you're just
wanting to see jake fight ksi then that
fight yeah like you said it'll always be
there yeah but if you want to look at it
as the biggest fight we can make in
youtube boxing we have to see
competition and for us to see that jj is
going to have to make up ground quickly
now i know and we know through misfits
they're going to have a ton of events in
the next year yeah but that level has to
start with slim or with whoever they're
going to fight next and it has to be
congruently like escalating fight after
fight and for jake to be as active as he
is
it's just hard to see
unless jake has a stumbling block which
i mean obviously anderson is that
stumbling block anderson could well
[__] be that guy to go back to
youtube boxing for you paul yeah like
that acting like it's a foregone thing
like oh jack's just gonna keep going no
like he's taking super tough fights and
anderson can derail this whole thing
absolutely so ksi jake like you said i
think it we have to see it as
competitive and the more that ksi gets
in there and shows
more ring time i think we can get a
better idea as to what that competitive
level will be
but as of right now it looks like we're
still a ways off yeah i just think by
jake even taking this fight it makes it
look that way but then like you say if
if if silva plays with him and it's not
competitive in any way
all of a sudden
jj is making videos laughing and uh oh
you got school yeah back the youtube
boxing for you pal come back come back
to me we'll have an actual fight because
that wasn't you know i can see how
it could go either way and you can see
that that
depending on how jake does the road is
either it's either going to be like
faster than the furious you know like
oh we're coming together here
it's sort of fascinating how this is
such a domino effect of a moment here in
this uh the new boxing scene that we're
seeing it's a level of one upsmanship
from both guys right like and and the
way i look at it is ksi his events he's
trying to up like one up jake's events
like ksi's entire event was immaculate
untouchable yeah yeah and you watch a
jake paul event and you're really
watching for jake right you're watching
for that main event like a most boxing
event let's not forget some of those i
mean not ben oscar an event where they
had all those dancers and singers
[__] hell it was bad it was terrible
nothing and and that's where like you
know misfits have nailed it and uh yeah
and we're i'm not just saying this
because we were a part of the show like
i
i couldn't give a [__] really like
two eyes and you can see though that's
that's the easiest thing to see
the best youtube boxing event that we've
ever seen in terms of the all-round
package
um so that's always going to be there jj
having that level of upsmanship if he
can then
level up the competition which i think
he's going to do with slim with you know
if it's tommy fury if he's able to to
match
the levels in competition and go boom
boom boom while keeping that event as
good as it is it makes his drawing power
and the jake fight even more realistic
because then jake sees [__] these guys
are putting on
ridiculous events and he's starting to
get to that level
then we can make that fight but one
little pebble in this road
and that's the hard part about this
fight we talked about it in studio
jake trips up you know against anderson
and that's not a pedal it's a [__]
boulder or if ksi has a struggle with
one of the the other guys he fights and
this fight again it just separates again
so we have to have everything almost go
perfect here we'll put a pin in it for
now we got to we got to for now oh yeah
i i want to talk to you about a couple
of more fights before we go um
fights coming up mcbroom gabe you've met
gabe recently you had a sit down with
him obviously his energy is always crazy
but um how are you feeling about the
fight coming up i love gib man i love
him to death um we sat down and uh one
of the biggest things in the interview
you can hear him breathing the whole
time
the microphone got him breathing and he
just he has this focus about him and
that's that's i guess where were my
biggest takeaway was he has this focus
and confidence in himself that he's
going to go in and take austin out this
fight is is massive for him and it's
massive for you know the youtube boxing
scene moving forward because
let's say gibb goes in and wins
all of a sudden he's back at the top of
the list here you know like he i don't
know he's talking
immediately then yeah yeah and and
another thing that you know we're
talking about gibb you know going in
shutting down the promotion doing all
this austin's not bad and i know this
because i've seen
too much of him to to and how quickly
he's gotten better
i don't know that people are giving
austin the credit of how good he could
possibly be in this sport with more time
and this is what worries me is that
people are and i i listen i'm gonna i
don't even care to tell you i'm gonna go
like gibbs got my heart man i can't i
can't go against getting
in love bro i know man that big nose
what do you want to do but
no but you know when you talk about a a
growth story as well um just to give you
a little bit of a backstory my first
ever commentary gig in youtube ever was
on this uh this thing called the wembley
cup that spencer um put together yeah
yeah yeah you might remember years ago
like
everyone was different
really different but gabe more so than
the other boys even i remember sitting
next to him
and he was chubby he looked like he'd
never worked out in his [__] life he
was saying to me like me i couldn't even
get on the school team and now here i am
playing at wembley yada yada crazy and
he was funny but he wasn't like
confident and aggressive and the person
he's become now when you see him
shredded in in his latest pictures and
all the work he's done with leon over
the years it's it's a great thing to see
someone
improve themselves and the biggest thing
i can give
give credit on is he did not let that
jake paul defeat slow him down he kept
going and we've seen like it ain't easy
to do that some people struggle with it
you know what i mean and he's
he's a [__] man gibb i've got i've
got me i've seen him train i told you
some stories
yeah the guy is he's got my [__]
respect and look mcbroom all i can say i
i haven't seen we haven't seen a lot of
them that that bryce hall fight was
trash in my opinion bryce hall not good
and he probably took longer than he
should have done to get him out of there
but you're gonna have to crack this guy
and nail him to the floor in order to
beat gabe in my opinion um because he's
going to keep coming
so
i'm i'm really excited to see the winner
of this because i think they could
potentially
leapfrog
slim
especially if it's mcbroom i i think
that's the only thing where slim looked
so good but mcbroom
ksi it's a it's a huge huge event
they've already got beef there the
problem i see for gibb is we're in tins
right we're in 10 ouncers and it doesn't
take a big time shot to put someone down
with 10. he could slap out a hook and
that's that's going to hurt right
and the thing i keep seeing in austin's
camp and this could be a good or bad
thing for austin is he continually looks
like he wants to play
counter fighter back foot snipe gibb on
the way in he's been talking about gibbs
bringing this pressure bring that
pressure bring it bring it i'm gonna you
know what i'm saying i'm gonna i'm gonna
take advantage of try and use the jake
paul blueprint and would move backwards
and crack him once
he wants to snipe and that's like i said
it's a dangerous game because all of a
sudden you might be and i know it's
austin's promotion so if you're down
three rounds really you're probably tied
three rounds but
if you're down
he's like oh we just won three we're
good but if if you're if you're taking
that approach and you can't snipe gibb
and all of a sudden the volume starts
adding up now you may be down three four
rounds and you know you have to turn it
around in those last two but
it's really going to come down to can
austin catch gibb coming in like he
plans on doing and can give into range
safely can he have that patient pressure
you know i think it's going to be
don't get me wrong look uh
i think he'll get cracked a few times
but i think he'll stay with it and i
think we may end up i would not be
surprised if we end up with a
controversial decision because yeah the
thing about gibb that i think people
don't uh appreciate now
uh because they've only seen that big
win he had recently against taylor but
it's educated pressure now it ain't it
yeah it i i think um if anything and
it's gonna happen
i i had of jj in his in his fight of how
he was entering how his shot selection
wasn't quite right like if you look at
gibb and the tail i hold the fight
that's how you [__] beat someone up
like you know what i mean with that
style educated pressure jabbing on the
way in judge the distance well um and i
think his his boxing iq is more improved
than what people think the only thing i
worry about with gibb is he shut taylor
down immediately and taylor was never
the same in that fight after that first
round he just couldn't get shots off can
he do the same to austin is austin going
to wilt away or is austin going to be
able to
ban something early or just be there
late
an arrogant bastard though which i i i
is great
it means he's not going to give up is
the way taylor did yeah yeah and that's
the problem too is like you have give
you know two or three rounds he banks in
but austin catches him in in four or
five and all of a sudden it's a
different round they're going six so
it's six threes i like that the only
thing and this is another thing i worry
about with gibb what is his ceiling
right like like as a boxer as a talented
boxer what is his talent ceiling because
we both know he even told me he's like i
didn't do a push up till i was 21. like
we don't like athleticism is not
something we no give before we know him
for hard work dedication pressure and
now he's starting to become that athlete
that we wanted his engine is is really
something i will give him that i think
that's where
he will surprise austin a little bit
with the level that he can keep up for
that length of time it's mad yeah
i just wonder and again experience like
this is why i'm going with gib he has
experience he has that engine he has
become a better boxer over that last
like the the amount of time he's put
into it has made him a pretty decent
boxer for this level austin is just a
different and i know we talked about him
being a basketball guy but he is a
different level of athlete
and he's picking this sport up quick
i would say just as quick as jake and
and logan did wow really yeah because i
haven't seen the same footage that you
have bro so that's just watching that's
really shocking his footwork i'm
watching some things he's doing and he's
a natural right-handed guy but he's
actually starting to look like a
southpaw
and uh i don't know that he's gonna look
as clean and crisp that he does in some
of his footage when give is in front of
him and that's going to be that's what
we're you know we're looking for the
ultimate test it's very hard when you
when you've got the tasmanian devil on
you yeah right and that's why jake was
so impressive like we in retrospect
right at the time we were like oh jake's
gonna run this kid over but in
retrospect gibb does that to everyone
except jake you know so it's like how
does austin look with that freak train
in front of him it's just i know that
austin being a decent level athlete to
begin with and starting to pick the
sport up pretty quickly i think he has
the ability to snipe gibb i just don't
think
if he doesn't do it he doesn't win this
fight i think gibb can easily win again
hopefully wins a decision in that
promotion but that's what i see i don't
know
one one last thing i will say is gabe's
got the [__] chin as well to be fair
to him like jake smashed him and he kept
with his teeth
yeah well the people dragged him with
tins and he didn't have the right it's
going to take
the shot of a lifetime from mcbroom and
if to be look if mcbroom does it
then there's your sale because i guess
you just because the guy who who spoiled
ksi for months on end and you know that
that's a that's a hell of a moment but
we're with gabe obviously we love gibb
and uh we believe in gabe the last fight
i want to talk about is uh an
interesting one that looks like it could
be happening in january on the next ksi
called logan paul dylan danish we are
finally
gonna see dylan dannis
i don't i don't think we're gonna see
really i don't i don't know because how
many times have we done this how many
times have we said
all right it's time dylan dennis x
person right yeah logan vs
i just don't know yet right and and i
would love to see it like dylan if
you're ready let's do it logan obviously
take some time off from wwe let's let's
get it
but i i i would love to see this fight
like dylan dylan was bitching about me
after i uh
i laughed at that because logan said
he's like the gum on the bottom of your
shoe
i was like it's so true though because
he is that person now in fighting where
he's just there like he never does
anything he's just chipping away he has
achieved nothing in terms of actual uh
striking even if he gets in there with
logan i'd have respect for him genuinely
because no because i think logan beats
the living [__] out of him yeah like
logan's definitely had an advantage here
but that's what i think people just want
to see him back up the things he said
continuously about the paul's and about
really anyone like you said he's just
jones you name it you name it he's just
around and all of a sudden you know he
has this opportunity and it seems like
you can't use the i wasn't healthy i'm
not saying it was an excuse but you
can't say that now like you are now
healthy you are training it is time now
to go and do this hopefully scott coker
is like yeah okay like go do this
whatever yeah yeah and i think that's
the fight man like please just i don't
know make it happen because i can't do
another one of these things where
dylan's like ah
you know two months later i don't know
what happened it didn't work out and
then man
this is the point though where if you're
a friend of dylan you got to go bro what
the [__] are you waiting for like you're
not getting
you're not getting a check anywhere else
yeah and can we talk about like yes this
card is is
potentially going to be stacked
from what i'm hearing behind the scenes
and i can't say too much but i'm hearing
this this is one they want to just blow
out of the [__] water ksi opponent
logan hopefully dylan other names that
are massive youtubers that i don't think
people even know about trying to be on
this card oh really you're talking about
they're talking
that's the good thing is now because you
know what [__] cloud chasers [__]
influences are they seeing the spotlight
they're like oh it was i wanted
everybody everybody came in hey that it
was such an amazing night that's the
thing why not yeah the hardest thing
about youtube boxing was getting people
to sign up now you got a queue it's
perfect i was gonna say now you have so
many people i've got one uh one one
question for that event sol papi
who would you put him with right now
salt poppy who could i put him with that
makes sense um jeez what a i mean okay
slim is a big
if right if slim gets the ksi fight you
can't put him with him but if he doesn't
that's a pretty decent i mean it's an
interesting match
slim kenny is a good one as well um and
i think that one might even just work
out more naturally just because they
they've all been in talks and stuff size
wise as well yeah size wise the reach is
there for for kenny oh man who does i i
saw a name a couple you know it was
funny i saw someone on twitter was like
why not go salt poppy in ksi and you
know keem is the the happy punch owner
and he was like i'm keeping salt poppy
as far away from ksi as possible
because i think people know like salt
poppy's dangerous you know oh yeah so
you
you know so you might want to keep him
just just keep him over here for a
couple of years you know and then maybe
but you got to build him up so that
fight when it happens you know yeah that
that
you know that's such a strange one
because look at the end of the day what
sol papi did was spectacular but who he
did it against wasn't right it doesn't
mean it's repeatable but that's why i'm
saying like if it's jj versus a mcbroom
and and then we have um
what about stop poppy gib me
if that if that fight happens
i don't know about you but i'm my fire
for mma
is dwindling a little bit lately because
because i've had so many fights i've
like
the the ufc in my opinion just isn't
being run very well since the wme
purchase like my my uh
fight promotion stuff is very weird to
me
yeah they're like wait till monday and
then here we go with this big event no
one says [__] about it beforehand though
yeah and also like you know fights that
i've been waiting for for so long and
not materializing and and i'm just
frustrated by
basically
mma is becoming everything that dana
used to criticize about boxing and this
is where we make the fight through and
it's
it's just not happening anymore um but
weirdly my excitement for that january
card
it's it's it's going to be
basically
it's probably going to be above aj
versus fury purely because i'm just
gonna be like what's gonna happen and
that's what as as fight fans that
feeling of what's gonna happen
yeah the fact that we have so many of
those on a full night of fights in
misfits is
i gotta give the guys credit that's
where the excitement's coming from
obviously it's not necessarily the skill
but i'm pumped for that january called
man it could be you know outside of jake
and uh you know ksi and the logan ksi
fights this could be the biggest one we
have for a long time depending on if the
names i'm hearing that are going to be
on this thing get on it if it's logan
and ksi on the same card it's a wrap
what happened outside of it yeah that is
that whatever they got in i mean there's
been a dispute of was it 500 was it 250
was it 300 whatever it was
they
they're going to the moon
to do 500 if they did that with that
like not only the card was was amazing
but to do it with those two people as
the main event with ksi you give ksi a
credible name oh my like tommy fury yeah
and logan on the card you're doing a
mill like you're doing at least a mill
all right brother it's been a pleasure
as always i know the people
love when we uh chop it up here
podcast everyone go and subscribe to
wade he's a [__] legend he's a
diamond and he's killing the game over
in america i've been trying to get him
to move to the uk so we could do more
content
um
but we'll see what happens over there
get over there man we'll do this brother
uh all right that's that's all from me
and wade thanks for watching don't
forget the like button and subscribe to
the true jordan youtube channel and
we'll see you later get 25 off the true
trueclassic.com with my code true and
get free shipping on orders over a
hundred pounds that's twenty-five
percent of trueclassic.com with the code
true